wird putins krieg dreckig nachdem er im
ersten anlauf seine ziele offenbar nicht
erreicht hat das wäre für die
ukrainische zivilbevölkerung eine frage
auf leben und tod und könnte der westen
massiven kriegsverbrechen vor den augen
der welt tatenlos zugesehen wenn nicht
weitet sich der konflikt dann doch aus
krieg in der ukraine wie kann ein
flächenbrand verhindert werden jetzt in
der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst zugeschaltet aus sie lief also
zu deutsch lemberg im westen der ukraine
ist rebecca bat sie sind berichten dort
von dort aus unter anderem für rbb
deutschlandradio und den tagesspiegel
und sie reisen seit wochen kreuz und
quer durch die ukraine in lemberg ist ja
auch ein sammelpunkt für viele
hunderttausend flüchtlinge die von dort
aus versuchen nach europa nach
westeuropa zu entkommen in münchen
begrüße ich carlo masala professor für
internationale politik an der
universität der bundeswehr und hier im
studio sind sonja zekri von der
süddeutschen zeitung korrespondentin in
berlin und rüdiger lüdeking ist
ehemaliger diplomat im auswärtigen
dienst im auswärtigen dienst der
bundesrepublik deutschland und
ehemaliger botschafter bei der osze der
organisation für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa und genau und
das geht es ja im zusammenhang mit dem
ukraine krieg ganz besonders frau bat
die erste frage an sie ebenso schlicht
wie wichtig wie ist die situation im
moment vor ort in lemberg
genauso wie sie es eben
angesprochen haben wir erleben sehr
viele flüchtlinge die hier in dieser
stadt einreisen und eigentlich versuchen
so schnell wie möglich weiter zu reisen
gleichzeitig bereiten sich die bewohner
dieser stadt eigentlich auch die
verteidigung der stadt vor um die stadt
herum
so jetzt ist das passiert was bei einer
leitung nach lemberg passieren kann vom
jüdischen frau
hat sie sind wieder zu hören und soll
ich mit herrn nötig die nicht einmal
bitte machen sie weiter so frau bat
bitte setzen sie noch mal an
wir haben sehr viele flüchtlinge die aus
der zentral und ost ukraine gerade nach
levi bekommen und eben versuchen das
land zu verlassen richtung polen oder
andere europäische länder gleichzeitig
bereiten sich die bewohner auch die
verteidigung der stadt vor viele läden
sind geschlossen
es gibt kaum mehr bargeld das ist jeden
tag ein kampf um bargeld zu bekommen und
so hat man eben eine ganz merkwürdige
atmosphäre in dieser stadt jeden tag sie
reden anlagen auch aber es gibt gott sei
dank noch keinen beschluss und das
wollen wir auch hoffen dass die
leitungen nach lemberg steht solange die
sendung andauert der dritte ging die
ukraine kämpft ja ganz offensichtlich
mit dem die ukrainer und ukrainerinnen
ganz offensichtlich mit den mut der
verzweifelten bisher hält ja der
widerstand hat sich da putin eine
fulminante fehleinschätzung geleistet
was diesen waffengang was diesen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine an geht
danach sieht es sehr aus es war offenbar
so gedacht ursprünglich von seiner seite
das waren 1 enthauptungsschlag
durchführt die regierung die ihre
jetzige ukrainische regierung durch eine
marionettenregierung ersetzt und dann
vielleicht leichtes spiel hat wie eben
in belarus aber er hat sich glaube ich
nicht nur in der in der
durchhaltefähigkeit der regierung
getäuscht sondern er hat auch sich sehr
getäuscht dass er eigentlich das gesamte
ukrainische volk gegen sich hat und
jetzt sie hatten denn der in der
anmoderation vom dreckigen krieg
gesprochen es kann durchaus sein dass
wir das jetzt in den nächsten wochen
erleben müssen und das ist sehr sehr
bitter und ich muss sagen nicht
beeindruckt wirklich die art und weise
wie die ukraine darauf steht und welchen
eindruck sie macht auch auf die welt wie
man heute gesehen hat ist ja im grunde
putin vollkommen allein das wasser zum
schluss angesprochen hat das ist auch
die frage die ich an herrn x sala
stellen will eine knappe woche dauert
geht es dieser angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine an sind wir da gerade an einem
entscheidenden punkt kann der krieg
jetzt wirklich dreckig werden
ja der krieg hat das potential dreckig
zu werden also wenn die berichte stimmen
das thermo bayerische warnungen vor ort
sind das die sogenannten tu es einst vor
ort sind was letzten endes gigantische
flammenwerfer sind dann kann dieser
krieg durchaus in eine phase treten ich
sage mal die ähnlich im kampf um grosny
oder sozusagen der situation entspricht
das heißt wo ohne rücksicht auf
zivilisten
zivile gebäude zerstört werden
zivilisten geschossen werden sind noch
nicht so weit aber das potenzial ist
sicherlich da gut dass heute noch dazu
sagen thermo bayerische waffen das sind
sogenannte vakuum bomben die bei der
explosion ein unterdruck in der umgebung
erzeugen wer nicht durch hitze oder
sprengstoff getötet wird wird dem wird
dann die lunge zu rissen also ein eine
bombe die auch völkerrechtswidrig ist
oder völkerrechtlich geächtet ist rosig
wie der westen muss reagieren er
reagiert ja auch kann er gar nicht
anders als das was wir jetzt gerade
erleben mit aufrüstung mit verstärkter
verteidigung in deutschland wir werden
später noch drüber reden die 100
milliarden euro und muss er auch mit
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine auch
deutschland reagieren angesichts der
bilder die uns da seit einer woche aus
der ukraine erreichen
ja ich glaube die bilder lassen
niemanden kalt der das sieht also auch
die kinder die man sieht und natürlich
denkt man an großen die kinder im keller
im winter da ist natürlich sozusagen der
der reflex dass man jetzt unbedingt
etwas tun will ich sehe sehr groß was
schwieriger ist es tatsächlich dann auch
die überlegung zu haben was würde das
denn eigentlich bedeuten wenn wir uns
mehr engagieren natürlich ist der hilfs
reflex der hilfs reflex da aber
sozusagen die die die gefahr dass dieser
konflikt sich ausweitet das dann doch es
irgendwann mal es kommen jetzt schon
internationale freiwillige in die
ukraine und kämpfen da aus verschiedenen
ländern aus amerika aus skandinavischen
ländern das so zu sagen da so eine
entgrenzung drin ist und dass wir dahin
als wir dann irgendwann doch ganz
offiziell partei werden diese gefahr ist
schon gegeben und das sollte man auch
die hilfe waffenlieferungen ich meine
auch dass wir uns jetzt dass wir unsere
verteidigung wieder stärken und sagen
wir haben nicht zu wenig dafür getan
gegen diese ebenso mächtige wie
schlagkräftige russische armee die den
meisten armenia weit überlegen ist das
ist sie ja nach wie vor das ist ja auch
unsere armee also das was wir im moment
tun mit dem sozusagen wenn wir jetzt den
unsere verteidigung stärken und
nachrüsten dann sind das ja effekte die
die nicht ganz eintreten also die in
diesem krieg ja erstmal noch nicht so
sehr zum tragen kann privat der
widerstand der ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer der ist ja schon legendär
der widerstand hält ja
und aber ist das auf dauer durchzuhalten
da braucht man ja ein unglaubliches
selbstvertrauen eine unglaubliche moral
nicht nur am anfang sondern das ist ja
vor allen dingen auf der langen strecke
wichtig dass man sie dass man nicht
resigniert oder innerlich kapituliert
wie sehen sie das gerade bei den
menschen denen sie in lemberg oder
woanders in der ukraine begegnen
wenn das wird natürlich die zeit zeigen
und auch der verlauf dieses krieges ich
möchte ganz kurzen noch eine anmerkung
machen wir sehen sehr 2014 ausländische
kämpfer auf beiden seiten in diesem
krieg also das ist jetzt nichts neues
dass ausländische kämpfer hier der
ukraine zur seite stehen wie gesagt das
gibt es seit 2000 wird sich auf beiden
seiten der front
was die moral angeht ich bin tatsächlich
überrascht es ist ein mythos den die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer auch gerne
von sich erzählen dass sie eben so
widerstandsfähig sind und und immer
schon widerstand geleistet haben und ich
habe das leider eben auch selber als ein
doch leicht überhöhten mythos gesehen
und musste mich hier auf einmal
korrigieren der widerstand ist enorm und
er wird größer zunehmend größer die
frage ist jedoch wie lange kann man das
durchhalten wenn dieser krieg wirklich
sehr dreckig wird irgendwann wird eine
bevölkerung auch kurve ich gehe davon
aus dass man ihn aber nie ganz brechen
kann
auf diesen vergleich noch eingehen
lüdeking wie ist man wie kann man denn
den staatschef selensky war ja früher in
einem ganz anderen metier unterwegs er
war comedian gewesen ist ja
russischstämmige hat auch in ist auch in
russischer
russland viel aufgetreten jetzt scheine
ja irgendwie über sich hinaus zu wachsen
so eine weltweite nicht gestellt
geworden er ist eine lichtgestalt
geworden auch dadurch dass er fest zu
seiner haltung steht in kiew zu bleiben
und weiter die regierungsgeschäfte zu
führen und das ist auch wichtig für die
moral ich glaube dass gesamten
ukrainischen volkes und ich will auch
ganz ehrlich sagen und auch nochmal auf
frau einzugehen man muss dann natürlich
sehr vorsichtig sein also ideen die
schon mal lanciert worden sind wie zumal
der die einrichtung einer
flugverbotszone das ist
sehr sehr gefährlich weil wir dann
natürlich über das hinausgehen und dann
direkt wahrscheinlich involviert würden
in einen krieg weil nämlich eine solche
flugverbotszone überwacht werden sollte
aber man kann jetzt in der jetzigen
situation den ukrainern die waffen nicht
vorenthalten so sehr ich auch natürlich
sehe dass gerade die waffenlieferungen
vielleicht auch zu einem blutigen krieg
führen zu einem erhöhten blutzoll aber
man muss natürlich honorieren dass die
ukraine in der klaren entscheidung
stehen dass sie sich verteidigen wollen
und dann kann man also nicht anders als
ihnen helfen selbst und dann vielleicht
hoffen dass das kalkül was putin hat
nicht aufgehen bzw er ein anderes kalkül
jetzt ansätze und nicht in einen
wirklich dreckigen krieg einen streich
wir kommen gleich auf den gedanken
zurück vorjahr nochmals lenski sein
cooles auftreten damit macht für die ja
erst recht putin agentur vor
also ich glaube putin warf ihn in weiten
kreisen ohnehin schon immer eine
karikatur also dieser männlichkeitskult
dieses mit nacktem oberkörper durch die
tiger reiten das ist jedoch eher fürs
heimische publikum gewesen das hat im
westen ja nie wirklich gezündet die
frage natürlich ist sehr leicht die
beiden so gegeneinander zu halten der
volksnahe sie lenski der sozusagen sich
mit seinem verteidigungsminister dann
arm in arm zeigt das ist natürlich auch
es ist maria krüger es ist die macht der
bilder und gleichzeitig dann muss man
schon auch sagen die ukraine ist dem
krieg russland ist im krieg und auch mit
bildern wird krieg geführt und dieser
mann aus dem volk der gesagt hat ihr
müsst nicht mein bild in euren
schreibstuben haben oder in den büros
sondern hängt dann bilder von euren
kindern dahin das ist natürlich uns viel
näher das ist moderner das ist
demokratischer und dann sieht man diesen
15 meter langen tisch von putin der ja
nicht mal seine minister in ihnen
sozusagen auf armlänge an sich
heranlässt ich bin nur ehrlich gesagt
bei aller macht der bilder nie ganz
sicher inwieweit das am ende tatsächlich
zum begreifen des konfliktes beiträgt
oder auch zu lösen guter wollen wir
heute eine schippe drauf zu gehen auf
das begreifen haben als er gerade ist ja
schon der begriff flut flugverbotszone
gefallen
das wäre eine möglichkeit die aber ja
kaum durchsetzbar ist sie würde ja zum
kriegführen mit mit nato-staaten wie
lange wird denn der widerstand oder wie
lange wird die ukrainische armee nach
ihrer einschätzung diesen widerstand
halten können sie hält ihn ja schon
länger als eigentlich gedacht auch von
den russen gedacht oder russischen armee
wie lange wird sie das noch durchhalten
können aus militärischer sicht
also man muss vielleicht
damit kein falscher eindruck entsteht
sagen dass die operation der russischen
streitkräfte zwar schleppend läuft aber
letzten endes nicht schlecht läuft
also sie haben heute zum beispiel eine
strategisch wichtige stadt eingenommen
die ihnen erlaubt die mär von der
südöstlichen küste zu kontrollieren
in den vom bett besser vorzustoßen und
möglicherweise odessa einzunehmen sie
sind dabei kiew 1 zu zügeln also das
heißt sozusagen hier kämpfen ich zwei
momentan gleiche gegner einen kampf
sondern die ukrainische armee ist dabei
diesen kampf zu verlieren das muss man
ganz deutlich sagen und man kann ich
sagen wie lange das dauern wird aber es
wird keine es keinen krieg sein der sich
monatelang hinziehen wird es wird eine
frage von wochen sein nochmal zu der
flugverbotszone sollen gesagt worden ist
der flugverbotszone ja die muss
überwacht werden aber damit dass jeder
auch richtig begreift eine
flugverbotszone bedeutet krieg bedeutet
das nach staaten in einen krieg mit
russland eintreten weil sie rot der
kampf flugzeuge abschießen und über
diese tatsache hinaus wenn man sich das
geografisch anschaut ist die nato gar
nicht in der lage eine solche
flugverbotszone einzurichten sie
brauchen die entsprechenden
abwehrsysteme die können sie nicht in
weißrussland und in der ukraine fest
stationieren die stationieren sie dann
in den baltischen staaten
unsere patriots mit der entsprechenden
bewaffnung reichen 60 kilometer damit
kommen sie nicht nach kiew rein und
gleichzeitig machen sie natürlich dann
die baltischen staaten zum legitimen
anschlussprojekt russischer gegenschläge
also eine flugverbotszone bedeutet krieg
und ist nicht durchsetzbar in dieser
gegenwärtigen situation freibad was sie
da es gerade gehört haben von professor
masala das auf sicht doch die ukraine in
diesem kampf unterliegen wird ist bei
den menschen in der ukraine denen sie da
begegnen möglicherweise so ein ganz
diffuses gefühl da dass das doch schief
gehen könnte dass sie nicht siegen
obwohl sie ja einen solchen
verteidigungs und einen solchen
kampfeswillen entwickeln
aktuell nicht habe ich den eindruck wie
eben schon gesagt man hält auch diesen
mythos hoch dass man immer widerstand
geleistet hat egal was da kommen mag
ich halte es persönlich dennoch für
sinnvoll dass ich auch westliche
regierungen eben auch dieses szenario
einstellen dass wir
eine praline bald haben werden die eben
nicht mehr das land ist dass wir heute
kennen nicht mehr in den grenzen
existiert die wir heute kennen
oder eben in den grenzen aber unsouverän
und dann auch auf gegebenfalls weitere
verbrechen repression die auf dem
territorium der heute heutigen ukraine
stattfinden könnten und darauf muss sich
darauf einstellen und darauf müssen wir
eigentlich dann ja nicht reagieren
sondern am besten
agieren wenn nötig in westeuropa darauf
eingestellt auf eine solche situation
dass die ukraine unterliegt denn
irgendwie muss man dann ja reagieren
ich weiß es nicht offen gestanden also
ob die ukraine unterliegt ich teile die
einschätzung von herrn masala auch was
die militärischen dinge angeht und
militärisch wird die ukraine sicherlich
verlieren vielleicht im wochen das
dauert vielleicht noch wochen es kann
auch sehr schmerzhaft sein
was vielleicht noch eine lösung wäre und
ich weiß dass es sehr viele ich habe den
eindruck dass putin oder seine ängste
auto rasch nur diese entscheidung
getroffen hat überhaupt in den krieg zu
ziehen es gibt sehr viele ehemalige
hohe offiziere in russland aber auch
politikwissenschaftler die das durchaus
auch veröffentlichen die da sehr sehr
große sorgen haben und sich sogar dafür
aussprechen kurzfristig und
unbedingt oder unkonditioniert einen
waffenstillstand zu fordern ob diese
dinge eintreten das weiß ich nicht ich
habe er das gefühl das putin tatsächlich
sich einstellt auf einen schmutzigen
krieg den er durchziehen will sofern er
dort nicht jemand hat dem in den arm
fällt ich glaube schon dass er selbst
eine auto rasch sehr damit
überrascht hat aber wir müssen uns
ehrlich gesagt auf einen vielleicht
länger dauernden und auch gefährlichen
kalten krieg einstellen und ich glaube
die
wesentlichen
entscheidungen dazu sind gefallen und
die sind eigentlich schon überfällig
gewesen das heißt also die
beseitigung und die schnellstmögliche
beseitigung der fähigkeit und und
rüstungs defizite die wir zum beispiel
der bundeswehr haben die aber auch
natürlich die europäisierung der
verteidigung die wir jetzt ganz beherzt
heißt der steuer könnte aus dieser
entwicklung sogar positive
konsequenzen ziehen dass man gemerkt hat
dass es nur zusammen geht dass es mit
einer robusten verteidigung nur geht
dass das was man bisher als defizite in
der europäischen sicherheits- und
außenpolitik gesehen hat dann praktisch
putin heute gelesen ein amerika damit
meint eine anspielung gestern auf die
rede von joe biden aber er könnte auch
europa einen ganz gegen seinen willen
ich glaube es gibt eine ganze von von
aspekten und ich meine man kann
natürlich jetzt das ukrainische volk
bedauernd das natürlich in großer
einigkeit sich gegen den aggressor
wendet aber dass es gibt auch lehren die
daraus zu ziehen sind unter anderem auch
für china beispielsweise das ist ja sehr
sehr zurückhaltend geäußert hat und ich
hab manchmal die hoffnung dass man doch
vielleicht china auch bewegen kann eine
gewisse will ich sagen vermittlerrolle
zu übernehmen aber doch auch putin
einzuwirken dass er jetzt ist nicht zum
äußersten kommen lässt weil das gelingt
das eben die frage ist eine dynamik in
dem krieg jetzt die man gar nicht so
absehen kann man kann nicht sehen was
wird das ende sein aber wir müssen
natürlich vom ende her denken und das
bedeutet aus meiner perspektive zunächst
einmal dass wir uns schlechterdings
einstellen müssen auf einen kalten krieg
der auch eine rückversicherung zum
beispiel der baltischen staaten bedeutet
eine aufrüstung der der westlichen
staaten in
europa insbesondere und natürlich
vielleicht sogar eine vorne verteidigung
wie wir sie aus dem kalten krieg also
eine integrierte vorne verteidigung wie
sie aus dem kalten krieg fragen was
jetzt mit china angesprochen haben dass
möglicherweise die weltwirtschaft
ruiniert werden könnte mit diesem thema
wir uns morgen beschäftigt der phoenix
runde es wird jetzt immer wieder von
verhandlungen gesprochen ich glaube
jetzt sollen morgen welche angesetzt
werten zwischen der ukraine also
unterhändlern der ukraine und russlands
war für heute geplant morgen sondern die
stadt sind aber was gibt es da
eigentlich zu verhandeln
die frage ist wie viel daran es
verhandlung und wieviel einfach nackte
drohung also dies sozusagen das von
russischer seite einfach gedroht wird
selensky würde ich mal vermuten soll
gehen es ist ja immer wieder im gespräch
dass janukowitsch
eingesetzt werden soll das ist der
frühere der russische präsident der
durch die x dann wollte gestützt genau
der zweimal gestürzt worden ist und
sozusagen der komplett diskreditiert ist
der
wirklich also in der heutigen ukraine
auch in der heutigen situation keinen
rückhalt hat also ein kießling regime
das eingesetzt werden sollte
und die frage ist nachdem wie sich im
moment die die die männer und frauen in
der ukraine gegen die russische
besatzung werden und auch gegen die
gegen den krieg und gegen den einmarsch
dass die frage ob sie das akzeptieren
also selbst wenn er wirklich ist
hinbekäme selensky auf die eine oder
andere weise loszuwerden wenn man so
nennen will und dann so eine figur
einsetzt ob das wirklich russland diese
beherrschbare ukraine bringt dass das
ist ja noch sehr zu bezweifeln sie sich
vorstellen dass es jemals wieder ein
treffen zwischen westlichen politikern
und leuten wie putin und lauf wurf gibt
also leuten wie würde dann bedeuten
zwischen putin und lauf und westlichen
politikern heute ist es sich als es
heute ist es sehr schwer vorzustellen
andererseits muss man sagen der westen
hat sich um frieden zu schaffen mit
allen getroffen bis jetzt und da ist die
diplomatie kennt keine schmerzen und man
muss es auch machen um dann in
irgendeiner weise frieden zu bringen ich
bin nur nicht sicher ob auf der anderen
seite die bereitschaft besteht
einmal soll er das dilemma ist ja man
hat ja wenig alternativen man kann
natürlich russland die verhandlungen mit
russland wie immer die dann aussehen
werden eines tages geht er dann auch
nach der beendigung des krieges um die
frage wie die nato ihre ostflanke
absichert das ist ja gerade von
wiedeking auch schon skizziert worden
aber man hat ja nur diesen einen
verhandlungspartner der jetzt blut und
nicht wenig an den händen hat
gleichzeitig das dilemma dass es keine
alternative gibt es sei denn in
deutschland gibt es einen regime wechsel
wie muss der westen in dieser situation
umgehen auch gerade deutschland wo ja
der krieg in der ukraine auch die
menschen aufwühlt und sie sehen was man
da anrichten kann
naja ich glaube analyse kenne ja gerade
schon in den grundzügen skizziert es ist
sozusagen wir müssen darauf daran
erinnern dass die weste diplomatie
diplomatie ist die sozusagen mit harten
macht mitteln ausgestattet ist und die
sozusagen nicht auf ein bestimmtes set
in diesem diplomaten kasten verzichtet
und das ist und seine militärische
stärke und militärische macht und
deshalb ist es ja richtig dass jetzt
sozusagen olaf scholz zum beispiel am
sonntag in seiner rede ja unter anderem
von der wehrhaftigkeit gesprochen hat
also man erinnert sich wieder an die
alten prinzipien die hier in der
bundesrepublik lange zeit vergessen
wurden nämlich auf der einen seite
natürlich angebote machen also es geht
nicht darum jetzt in eine dauerhaft zur
konfrontation die hatten wir ja so auch
im kalten krieg dich abzugleiten wo nur
das militär spricht und dann es geht
darum auf der basis einer eigenen
verteidigungsfähigkeit die möglichkeit
sondern diplomatie zu entwickeln dann
liegt es natürlich auch an putin und
seinen getreuen diese möglichkeit zu
ergreifen aber wir müssen die fundamente
unserer außenpolitik neu gestalten ich
will jetzt auch einen praktischen punkt
und sagen integrierte vorne verteidigen
ich gehe davon aus dass die nato jetzt
auch realisiert dass die nach russland
wo nackte an die sie sich jetzt klar ich
gehalten hat 97 obsolet ist und dass wir
in der folgezeit also nach diesem
konflikt die dauerhafte stationierung
substanzieller kampfverbände in den
neuen mitgliedsstaaten der nato sehen
werden um einfach die abschreckende
wirkung gegenüber dem russischen
neoliberalismus zu eröffnen
format lassen sie uns immer ganz kurz
auf die menschen in der ukraine eingehen
sie habe jetzt gerade auch noch mal die
prognosen gehört was erwarten
beziehungsweise befürchten die menschen
der ukraine wenn putin
tatsächlich siegen sollte wovor haben
sie am meisten angst
ich habe leider die verbindung ist
leider wieder schlecht ich würde dann
wiederum halt nochmal
nein es geht nicht um sie sondern es
gibt den menschen der ukraine den ganzen
die ganze frage noch mal wiederholen
was erwarten bzw befürchten die menschen
in der ukraine
als putin den krieg gewinnen sollte die
haben ja schon gehört es spricht ja da
auch einiges dafür wofür wovor haben die
menschen am meisten angst bei einem
möglichen sieg von wladimir putin
wenn der aktuelle ist es so dass das
noch kein thema ist was hier im
öffentlichen diskurs gesprochen wird man
beschränkt sich da auf den auf den
widerstand der geleistet wird und ist
der festen überzeugung dass man das auf
irgendeine art und weise gewinnen kann
weil man ja offenbar total unterschätzt
worden ist so ist aktuell der diskurs
hier und ich muss ehrlich sagen ich
finde es auch etwas
merkwürdig dass wir hier von einem
kalten krieg sprechen denn ich denke wir
sollten wirklich in betracht ziehen dass
wir hier einen partisanenkrieg erleben
werden selbst wenn hier fällt wenn die
regierung abgesetzt wird die einsetzung
wenn diese medienberichte stimmen das
wirklich ein cockpit im gespräch wird
zeigt einfach nur dass das russische
dass die russische regierung keine
ahnung hat von der realität in diesem
land und dann muss sie das mit wirklich
brutaler gewalt hier niederschlagen und
das der bilder wir sollten uns darauf
einstellen das ist eine reale gefahr und
nicht von einheiten wir kriegen als wenn
das russische verschiedene gewinnen
könnte und dann ist praktisch ruhe das
wird so nicht eintreffen die menschen
werden widerstand leisten auf die
ukrainische armee oder irgendwelche
untergrund gruppierungen die sich dann
bilden werden werden hier keine ruhe
geben auf jahre das heißt nötig dafür
ist dafür habe es kurz dazwischen kommen
wenn man soll ja damit kein
missverständnis bild ich glaube
sozusagen alle kennen und ich rede vom
kalten krieg im verhältnis russland
wurde im westen wir reden nicht vom
kalten krieg aus einer situation die in
der ukraine existieren wird da gebe ich
ihnen viel also ergebnis ihnen recht
dass grund ein szenario diskutiert haben
aber sozusagen die große politische
wetterlage zwischen russland
europa und den usa wird der eines kalten
krieges gleichen das ist glaube ich dass
wir beide damit gemeint haben dann
nehmen wir dort erstmals ist definitiv
ich vermute mal der botschaft auch ja ja
dann aber trotzdem die anregung und das
stichwort von format noch mal auf wenn
russland dieses land besiegt
gleichzeitig in schutt und asche gelegt
hat und dann beginnt dieser
partisanenkrieg oder eine hybride
kriegsführung dann wird russland mit
dieser beute nicht vor nein überhaupt
nicht also es war ist wahrscheinlich
auch nicht richtig wenn wir sprechen von
gewinnen oder verlieren ich hab das ich
habe den eindruck dass russland ohnehin
verliert schon jetzt hat es sehr stark
verloren dadurch dass es natürlich die
aufrüstung wenn man so will des westens
herausgefordert hat es zeit einen hohen
preis auch wirtschaftlich es wird ja
jetzt auch schon deutlich wie stark zb
der rubel verfallen ist es ist jetzt es
hat auch den den den part von china
übernommen als bösewicht in der welt ist
es isoliert wir haben das gerade gesehen
auch bei der abstimmung heute abend in
der generalversammlung der vereinten
nationen das passt nicht und ich glaube
schon deshalb habe ich ursprünglich
nicht damit gerechnet dass putin einen
so umfassenden krieg gegen die ukraine
an zetteln würde denn selbst wenn
150.000 soldaten hat aufmarschieren
lassen das reicht nicht aus um ein land
zu besetzen und wenn er ein
marionettenregime dort installiert dann
ist das maritim natürlich darauf
angewiesen dass es auch kräfte
vielleicht im lande gibt die es stützt
und das ist also eine sache die ist
eigentlich und da sollte eigentlich
russland ja auch gelernt haben
vielleicht aus anderen beispielen die
jetzt nicht genau passen aber die
vergleichbar sind wie afghanistan
dass man so nur verlieren kann auf die
lange frist gesehen wenn wir uns das
alles an höfe sind wir dann lichtjahre
entfernt von einer neuen friedensordnung
in europa die alte haben wir jetzt
glaube ich habe gerade gerade zu grabe
getragen also der der entscheidende
punkt ist einfach wie lange bleibt putin
an der macht das ist die frage die die
natürlich
die alles entscheidet so lange er im
moment an der macht ist und natürlich
wünschen sich alle menschen die ukraine
ganz besonders aber natürlich auch hier
hier
feinste haarrisse in unter den eliten zu
sehen und man ließ dann von oligarchen
oder milliardären ganz vorsichtige
distanzierungen aber
nichts deutet im moment darauf hinten
darauf also sozusagen nichts sollte
darauf hin dass es ein putsch geben
könnte dafür ist die armee von ihm zu
sehr aufgerüstet worden dafür ist sie zu
abhängig inzwischen offenbar ein noch
bestimmender faktor als der geheimdienst
man hat ja lange gedacht er kommt aus
dem geheimdienst putin viele hohe ämter
sind mit geheimdienstleuten setzt und
der geheimdienst ist die entscheidende
die entscheidende faktor jetzt stellt
man fest auf einmal ist der sergej
schoigu der verteidigungsminister die
eine ganz wesentliche rolle spielt man
hofft auf den aufstand oder die kritik
oder ein abrücken der geschäftsleute der
milliardäre
die bislang immer auch abgefunden wurden
für sanktionen unter denen sie gelitten
haben mit staatsaufträgen unter anderem
im rüstungssektor
man sieht diese unglaubliche tapferen
menschen die da in petersburg oder in
anderen städten auch in moskau auf die
straße gehen und zu tausenden abgeführt
werden
nichts davon deutet im moment darauf hin
dass da irgendetwas wankt also muirfield
man natürlich hört man das alles und man
wünscht es sich aber dass da wirklich
die risse sind im moment
sehe ich nicht was ich aber natürlich
dann auch ändern kann schon mancher
diktator ist über einem krieg gestürzt
format noch eine frage an den ersten
tagen wenn in den ersten tagen des
angriffs auf die ukraine ist ja die atom
ruine von tschernobyl erobert worten von
russischen soldaten das größte
kernkraftwerk in der ukraine ist auch
gefährdet möglicherweise wird es in
kampfhandlungen einbezogen oder
unter anderem neben anderen katastrophen
in der ukraine auch eine nuklear
katastrophe
ich kann natürlich nicht in die zukunft
gucken und etwas derartiges nicht
ausschließen was ich aber sagen kann ist
dass keine kriegspartei interesse hat
das größte
atomkraftwerk europas zu treffen
also von allem was ich weiß versucht man
auch mit den menschen die eben dort
arbeiten und die versuchen dieses
atomkraftwerk am laufen zu halten
absprachen zu treffen dass man gewisse
militärische position eben nicht in der
nähe stationiert so dass das eben
getroffen werden könnte aber natürlich
rein theoretisch klar kann man das nicht
ausschließen das wäre eine katastrophe
aber das wäre fünf beide parteien
gleichermaßen eine katastrophe und
dementsprechend haben beide ebenso ein
interesse dass das eben nicht dazu kommt
man soll wir fragen ja nach einem ob es
einen schrecklichen krieg geben kann in
der ukraine
das haben wir schon angesprochen glauben
sie dass tatsächlich da auch
massenvernichtungswaffen eingesetzt
werden können über die vakuum bombe
haben sie vorhin schon referiert es gibt
auch den verdacht oder die vermutung im
fall eines falles könnte die russische
armee chemiewaffen also giftgas
einsetzen es gab heute eine meldung dass
verschiedene westliche
sicherheitsexperten einen atomwaffen
einsatz für möglich halten und zwar
nicht gegen den westen sondern mit
taktischen atomwaffen in der ukraine um
den krieg schnell zu beenden und größere
verluste auf russischer seite zu
vermeiden sind das nur horrorszenarien
oder könnte das tatsächlich zumindest
zum teil eintreten
also ich glaube wir müssen trennen denn
die frage des einsatzes von chemiewaffen
und biologischen waffen und die frage
des einsatzes von nuklearwaffen also
taktischen nuklearwaffen
chemiewaffen gegebenenfalls biologische
waffen würden und dann sinn machen wenn
die strategie komplett umschlägt und es
sozusagen auf einen vernichtungskrieg
gegenüber der ukraine und ihrer
zivilbevölkerung hinausläuft
das ist zum gegenwärtigen zeitpunkt
nicht abzusehen das würde bedeuten aber
die russische armee erleidet über große
verluste die ukrainische armee ist in
der lage territorien zurückzugewinnen so
dass es so aussieht dass die russische
armee möglicherweise eine niederlage
erleiden an verschiedene stellen dann
könnte wirklich dieser wechsel in der
strategie stattfinden dann könnten diese
waffen vermehrt zum einsatz kommen
danach sieht es aber momentan absolut
nicht aus deswegen ist da viel
alarmismus dabei man sollte das im
hinterkopf verhalten aber momentan ist
das allein ist praktischer nuklearwaffe
ja da gibt es jetzt diese berichte
letzten endes muss man sagen eine
taktische nuklearer für die situation in
der ukraine ist völlig aus das macht
militärisch keinen sinn weil es wird
dann müsste sozusagen wirklich zu rosig
kurz vor ihrer vernichtung stehen und
dann sozusagen diese taktische
nuklearwaffen einzusetzen so wie es
momentan läuft gibt es keinen sinn es
würde sinn machen um uns um die
westlichen gesellschaften davon
abzuschrecken die ukraine weiterhin
militärisch zu unterstützen
aber als gefechtsfeld war für in der
ukraine selbst dann müsste sich die
situation so dramatisch gegen die
russische armee reden das ist momentan
einfach nicht abzusehen lüdicke ich habe
in meiner antwort ration vorhin gefragt
ob der westen sollten solche
massenvernichtungswaffen tatsächlich
eingesetzt werden den wirklich tatenlos
zusehen kann so nach dem motto wenn wir
nichts tun
dann machen wir uns nicht schuldig
anders als das dilemma dass man eben
tatsächlich nicht eingreifen kann was
würde das bedeuten auch für die reaktion
im westen wenn diese
massenvernichtungswaffen die in syrien
der eingesetzt worden sind auch so nah
an oder mitten in europa kann man sagen
eingesetzt wird war zunächst noch wo
sich die analyse von hermes anteilig
voll und ganz
putin hat natürlich diese ominöse
drohung ausgesprochen um den westen vor
allen dingen abzuschrecken
wir müssen natürlich auch auf das 1 1 in
der ukraine ja ja gut wir müssen aber
trotzdem aufpassen dass wir da nicht in
einen kampf uns involvieren lassen durch
die russische seite ein einsatz in der
ukraine ich glaube auf denen sind wir so
also gar nicht so eingestimmt und ich
halte ihn auch nach wie vor für nicht
sehr wahrscheinlich aber
sollte so etwas passieren dann ist
natürlich eine ganz neue situation da
und ich glaube auch dass und ich hatte
bisher immer den eindruck aber ich mich
wohl offenbar getäuscht dass putin ein
zwar mag halt ich und riskant
kalkulieren da macht politiker ist aber
dass kein wahnsinniger ist jetzt hat man
den eindruck er verfolgt eine
historische mission er möchte noch einen
eintrag in die geschichtsbücher für sich
sichern und das kann natürlich nicht
machen wenn er zum beispiel die ukraine
zerstört durch massenvernichtungswaffen
wobei ich sagen muss man muss da auch um
das noch mal deutlich zu sagen
unterscheiden zwischen atomwaffen und
chemiewaffen die eigentlichen im
strengen sinn wenn man so will keine
massenvernichtungswaffen sind und
biologische waffen auch wohl
massenvernichtungswaffen sind aber
eigentlich auch kaum einsetzbar sind
weil deren
wirkung nicht kontrollierbar ist also
insofern schon jetzt wird putin das
große problem haben auch seine eigenen
auto rasch zu
erklären warum er diesen bruder krieg
angezettelt hat und warum er
städte wie zum beispiel oder auch
charkiw die ja auch für russland eine
historische bedeutung hatten zerstört
und auch die menschen dort jetzt
zunehmend zerstört und getötet werden
durch diesen schmutzigen krieg und jeder
krieg auch in einer stadt wird schmutzig
sein und das fürchte ich er wird dieses
risiko eingehen wollen so lange an der
macht das denn er weiß wenn er den krieg
verliert ist das das ende seiner macht
und er wird auch dann nicht denn das als
autokrat überleben dh das ansehen von
putin ist ja jetzt schon demoliert da
kann ja eigentlich nichts gutes mehr in
den geschichtsbüchern stehen auch wenn
er selbst kulturelle güter in seiner
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft die ja auch
russland zu gerechnet werden dann
zerstört also ich glaube in unseren
geschichtsbüchern würde die darstellung
von wladimir putin ohnehin völlig anders
ausfallen als russischen
geschichtsbüchern insofern muss man da
schon sehr unterscheiden aber die frage
die sich natürlich stellt herr lüdeking
als sehr angesprochen was will er
eigentlich wirklich also was ist
wirklich sein ziel will er die ukraine
als ganze so zu sein wirklich
zerstückeln eine rumpf ukraine übrig
lassen ein teil an russland geben und
einen teil irgendwie dem westen
überlassen oder will er und auch das
halte ich nicht mehr für ganz
ausgeschlossen
will er nach der ukraine das ist ja die
große angst die beispielsweise auch die
baltischen staaten haben geht es
wirklich darum so eine russische welt zu
sammeln eine eine also sozusagen nicht
nur imperialistisch sondern
sozusagen dieses dieses groß russische
reich was mit nationalistisch auch gar
nicht richtig umschrieben ist wo dann wo
er dann russische bevölkerung
irgendwo in ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken
sozusagen auf die eine oder andere weise
wieder an russland heranführt und wenn
wir davon reden und das ist nicht
ausgeschlossen dann ist die ukraine egal
wie dieser krieg ausgeht ein schritt
aber sie ist nicht das ende und mir geht
es genauso wie vielen anderen auch auch
den intensivsten russland beobachtern
ich hätte das vor drei wochen nicht
gesagt ich halte das inzwischen nicht
mehr für ausgeschlossen dass es um die
ukraine
so sehr er auch eine obsession mit
diesem land hat dass die ukraine nicht
mehr das ende von eigentlich die frage
ob er nach dem basar militärisch gerade
zeigt überhaupt noch die kraft hat das
dann noch zu erweitern dieses groß ich
ja wenn ich da ja der einsatz zu sagen
darf also da würde ich sagen historisch
mann soll die russische armee auch wenn
sie da sehr reingestolpert ist und
stümperhaft und die panzer stehen
überall rum und haben keinen keinen
sprit mehr da darf man die russische
armee auch nicht unterschätzen boppard
lassen sie das nochmal auf die menschen
der ukraine schauen sind die menschen
der ukraine denn mit dem zufrieden was
jetzt an unterstützung aus dem westen
kommt man hat ja deutschland scharf
kritisiert
vor ausbruch des krieges da würde zu
wenig unterstützung kommen ich meine
sowohl die funktionen mit denen man
versucht die russische wirtschaft in die
knie zu zwingen als auch
waffenlieferungen
militärische unterstützung die wir heute
gehört haben sind ja die waffen der
bundeswehr also panzerabwehrraketen und
die 500 boden luft raketen vom singer ja
in der ukraine angekommen sind die
menschen damit zufrieden finden sie das
gut oder erwarten sie noch mehr
unterstützung
ich denke das kommt immer darauf an auch
wenn man fragt tendenziell merken die
menschen die verschiedenen arten der
unterstützung die es gibt also dass
waffenlieferungen sind ob das
solidarität demonstrationen sind ob das
harte sanktionen sind also alles oder
eben das was jedes land sozusagen
beitragen möchte kommt durchaus ja alle
ob das von der regierung kommt oder eben
aus der zivilgesellschaft wie diese
demonstration und hier hat man den
eindruck jetzt vor allem zukauf
deutschland das ja die die deutsche
liste endlich verstanden haben er hat
einige wochen vor dem russischen angriff
an junge frau gesagt ihr lebt doch in
einer blase da in euren friedlichen
westen und ich glaube das ist etwas
was was viele menschen der ukraine
tatsächlich so empfunden haben dass wir
kein reales bild kein realistisches bild
von der russischen führung haben
masala waffenlieferungen ich glaube
nahezu jedes nato land hat geht es
irgendwie waffensysteme in die ukraine
geliefert aber waffenlieferungen da ist
man ja schon relativ nah dran am
konflikt man cries da zwar nicht ein mit
eigenen truppen und eigenen waffen aber
man liefert waffen ist das für den
westen letztendlich auch gefährlich
diese waffenlieferungen
also rein völkerrechtlich gesehen nein
es gibt der russischen föderation
keinerlei legitimation sgr und sozusagen
maßnahmen gegen die staaten zu ergreifen
die diese waffen liefern also von daher
ist man da auf der sicheren seite so zu
sagen es ist nicht gefährlich was da
gerade betrieben es ist letzten endes
resultiert auch aus einer verpflichtung
heraus einem start bei seinem
völkerrechtlich gegebenen recht also
seinen legitimen recht auf individuelle
selbstverteidigung zu helfen also
anderswo wird sogar ein schuh draus es
ist eigentlich eine völkerrechtliche
verpflichtung nicht in stein gemeißelt
aber einem start dieses recht auf
selbstverteidigung nicht zu verwehren
das heißt aber eine vergeltung von
russischer seite müssen wir da nicht
befürchten für diese waffenlieferungen
wie immer die dann auch aussieht
schauen sie bislang ist es so ich habe
mich heute auch ein völkerrechtler
unterhalten neben mir sagte im news in
bello also im humanitären völkerrecht
muss man ganz einfach feststellen dass
momentan bei all dem was wir wissen die
russische armee sich mehr oder weniger
am news in bello hält
wenn wir jetzt davon ausgehen und das
wäre die voraussetzung dass natürlich im
kreml ein irrer sitzt und das ist nicht
meine wahrnehmung dann ist natürlich
überhaupt nichts mehr auszuschließen
also dann ist auch nicht auszuschließen
dass man sozusagen maßnahmen ergreift
gegen die bundesrepublik deutschland
weil die bundesrepublik deutschland
panzern man zahlt für raketen dorthin
liefert aber so wie es gerade aussieht
so zu sagen ist das nicht zu erwarten es
wäre eine andere sache gewesen wenn
diese
flugzeug also sache die borel
angekündigt hat wenn die sich realisiert
hätte was sie gott sei dank nicht hat
also das heißt das ukrainische piloten
abholen gehen dort sich in mix einsätzen
von dort aus in die ukraine fliegenden
den luftkampf führen und dann dem mix
wieder nach polen zurück fliegen das
wäre eine völlig andere situation
gewesen damit wir polen sozusagen mit
der bereitstellung eines flugfeldes
indirekter konfliktpartei geworden das
hätte eine ganz andere installations-
dynamik aber das was wir momentan haben
unter der annahme dass sich die russen
noch einigermaßen an regeln halten
rechtfertigt und wir werden nicht
vergeltungsschläge militärischer art
gegen staaten sehen die waffen
es war unter ihrem das national
warum sozusagen jetzt plötzlich putin
die alarmbereitschaft seiner
strategischen kräfte erhöht hat das
signal war an den westen haltet euch
daraus gut dann müssen sie jetzt mit
diesem satz auch bewenden lassen der
krieg geht leider furchtbarer weise
weiter und wir werden das auch weiter
verfolgen ich bedanke mich bei sonja
zekri bei rüdiger lüdeking bei carlo
masala und ganz besonders bei red
aus lemberg ihnen gilt unser besonderer
groß und einsatz der ganz bestimmt keine
floskel ist passen sie auf sich auf
liebe zuschauer morgen in der phoenix
runde
putins krieg wie einschneidend sind
sanktionen
es geht jetzt weiter im phoenix programm
mit phoenix der tag und constanza platz
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]